i'd to share
a story with everyone
a story that really touched my heart
many years ago when i learned of it and
when i read it this story is collected
by imam
in his book
this is a story about the importance of
the words of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam to the companions just
how wha what kind of esteem
the companions held the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's words
his breaths anything that he said they
would
take it and and and hold on to it and
implement it
but i also want to share this story
because in it
is an indication of what should be
important
and what our priorities in this life
should be
it's a story about jabba
the companion of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the son of the companion
of the prophet salallahu
that he had heard a narration
but he couldn't find anyone in medina
who had heard it directly from the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
knew the narration he just wanted to get
as
close in narration to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam as possible
so he was told that one of the
companions
was living in hashem a sham of syria and
and and those areas it's about a month's
travel at that time
[Arabic recitation]
i bought myself a riding animal
i packed my belongings and prepared
myself for journey
and i went to hashem i met their
abdullah
just to hear that narration from him but
here's the key he said
i was afraid that i would die
before having heard this narration from
him
just think about that for a minute this
is the priorities that the companions
had
i am afraid that i will die not having
this
knowledge when i go and stand in front
of allah subhanahu wa dad
and so when a person dies
what does he take with him really
if you want to know what you're going to
take with you when you die
look at what you take with you when you
go to sleep
the only thing you have that you will
take with you
is your knowledge your understanding of
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
his names and attributes your beliefs
your past your deeds your relationship
with allah
this is the only thing you will take
with you and this is what grows and
matures your soul
even as your body decays and so
every tuesday tuesday evening from 6 to
seven here at the mosque foundation
i myself we have a live streaming class
in the english language in which we go
through a book
called zad al-ma'ad provisions for the
day
of the great appointment the day of
resurrection
authored by the great and esteemed
scholar of islam
islam
this book deals with every aspect of the
prophet muhammad
how he spoke how he sat what he said
how he viewed the world his biography
how he walked his wives his companions
how he dealt with people
and so every week we sit for that hour
from six to seven
and we spend that time with the prophet
salallahu alaihi
wasallam we acquaint ourselves with him
we learn who he is
and that is what true love is true love
of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is not to be expressed
in superficial ways
i love him i i enjoy him or to wear a
shirt with
or to sing a song this is not how the
companions and how allah taught us
to celebrate the prophet sallallahu
alaihi was
say if you truly love allah then follow
me and allah in return will love you
this is how we truly express our love
for him
and you can only love him if you know
who he really is
and this is what we deal with every
tuesday the knowledge is free
you don't have to travel a month going
in a month coming
you don't have to do anything but go on
to the live stream
on facebook and listen
to an in-depth explanation of the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's legacy free of charge
just come with an open heart and an open
mind
we invite everyone to join us on that
night
it's very special to us all and it's a
book dear to my heart that i have spent
many years with
and i'd love to share it with you all
thank you very much
assalamualaikum